your car gets 25 miles per gallon
per gallon and you want to go on a
400 mile road trip
right now gas costs three dollars per
gallon
how much will the gas for your road trip
cost
so let's see they tell us they're going
on a 400 mile road trip for
400 miles
so the first thing that i'd want to
think about is well how many gallons am
i using and then once i know how many
gallons i'm using i know it's three
dollars per gallon so i can multiply the
number of gallons by three dollars
so to figure out the number of gallons
what i want to would i want to multiply
400 miles would i want to multiply that
times the
miles per gallon which is 25 or would i
want to multiply by the gallons per mile
well if i multiply by the gallons per
mile then i would get and i multiply
that times 400 then i would get the
number of gallons so let's just think
about that i want to multiply that times
so i want to multiply times and i'll
write the units first the gallons
the gallons per mile
the gallons per mile and what are the
gallons per mile
well we have 25 miles per gallon we have
25 miles for every
one gallon or you could say we have one
gallon for every 25 miles so i really
just took the reciprocal of 25 miles per
gallon and made it 1 over 25 gallons per
mile
now what do we get when we multiply
these two things the whole purpose was
to figure out how many gallons we're
going to use well we see that our miles
cancel out miles cancel out with miles
and then i have 400 times 1 over 25
gallons which is the same thing as 400
divided by 25 gallons so this is equal
to 400 over 25
gallons which is the same thing as 400
divided by 25 is equal to 16
gallons now it's always important to do
a reality check here not just to try to
blindly cancel out units does this
actually make sense that 16 is a much
lower number than 400
well sure it does and actually if you
have any experience filling up a car you
would sense that okay well that's about
the size you know on around 16 gallons a
car tends to go 300 or 400 miles if it
if it gets pretty good fuel mileage so
that just makes sense from experience
and also makes sense based on how it's
stated you get 25
miles per gallon so you're going to need
fewer gallons than you're going to need
miles so this all seems to make sense so
far but we haven't answered their
question they want to know how much will
my trip cost right now we've just
figured out how much fuel we're going to
use so then we could take our 16 gallons
16 gallons and to figure out the dollar
cost so we're going to multiply it by
dollars per gallon or gallons per dollar
well if we're thinking just about unit
conversion we want to multiply times the
dollars per gallon
so i could write it like this
i could write it like dollars per gallon
actually let me just write out the word
dollar
dollars
per gallon the units will con will will
cancel out and it also makes sense if i
whatever number of dollars per gallon i
multiply it times the number of gallons
and that's going to tell me how much
it's going to cost this happens at the
fuel pump every day hey it's three
dollars per gallon i'm gonna fill up 16
gallons hey three times 16.
so let's do that so it's three
dollars per gallon we see the gallons
cancel out and we are left with
16 times three dollars
16 times three
dollars
which is the same thing as 48 dollars
and we are done